every week on the financial confessions
host Chelsie Fagan gets the most
interesting people to share the money
truths mistakes and hard numbers they
normally never talk about learn how
people like Graham Stevens Ingrid Nilsen
Gretchen Rubin and Ashley C Ford
navigate money and learn about money in
a way you can actually understand start
listening to the financial confessions
today at the financial diet.com
slash podcast that's the financial
diet.com slash podcast hello and welcome
to another episode of not too deep I'm
your host grace Helbig today we have
Christian Pierce with us he is the
creative brain brawn the beauty behind
real pros of Simi Valley season 3 is
about the start on Facebook watch you
might know him from Jimmy Tate Rose
videos you might know him as that cool
dude with the handle that you can't
pronounce on Twitter or Instagram we
talked about his whole journey into the
creation of real brows and all the other
projects he's working on we also learned
that he is in a fight with his parents
and you know his favorite way to smoke
marijuana it's a fascinating episode all
the way around enjoy not too deep with
Kristian Pierce we're rolling we're here
we're doing it doing it we're here
Kristian Kristian chin that's right the
username like that I like it I I think
it's it's a nice phonetical way to let
people really know I thought it was
funny 19 I think it's fun anymore I kind
of it yeah what would you change it to
just your name by my real name your real
name yeah go a brand recognition right
right unless I think I'm like something
real funny it's like punny that's what's
going well okay here's I'm gonna open
with a question that I asked a lot of
people that are very multifaceted the
way that you are what is your deal was
my deal yeah girls ask me like usually
in a negative way no this is a positive
opportunistic way to kind of like
explain to people that don't know what
you're about what you do got it because
I always feel like when I try to if I'd
done some
and if I try to like describe how many
hats you wear I always feel like it's
inauthentic - probably how you see
yourself yeah it's funny I get asked
that question a lot no it's like being
someone that in like the content
creation world because it's so amorphous
and undefined but I'm sure people are
like how do I describe you I also kind
of shy away from that like answer cuz I
feel like I'll give the answer okay you
can shy away yeah I'm a writer actor
director producer all-around guy likes
to create stuff and make one snapshot
one-stop-shop exactly very cool what'd
they call me in high school okay so take
me through like the evolution of your
content creation because you and Jimmy
work closely together obviously yes and
this kind of started in college college
I was always like into like making home
videos and stuff yeah like when I was a
kid and I got kind of into making videos
like senior year high school when I got
to college that was like the first time
I was like away from home for a while
right where I could like I had like the
courage to actually be like okay this is
what I actually want to do you obey a
Zona in Tucson bear down what's that
school like I know nothing about it
other than now you went there right it's
it's a great school it's a lot of fun
really hot I don't do it with the heat
yeah that was tough yeah Arizona that's
probably the only thing I really know
about Arizona yeah I used to come home
in between classes to change clothes I'm
so sweaty it was nasty yeah school there
was cool Arizona is a not my favorite
state okay and Tucson is an interesting
City yeah yeah what's it what's the vibe
there what's it like part of it is like
very rocky and spread out like Arizona
isn't not much going on there's like a
artistic hub kind of that's have been
coming a lot of writers go there too
right because there's not many
distractions sure sure that makes sense
there's a crystal gem Michelle you may
have heard of its pretty big what is
this it's like a show or like people
from all over the world come here to
look at rocks oh yeah
- sounds big thing it's a very new agey
kind of area - right isn't there a lot
of like spiritual healing turquoise
right turquoise but the school is very
much like a big social party school yeah
a certain school took a lot of resources
and yeah Jimmy our pleasure in the same
fraternity okay and we were like two
older guys over from LA and then two of
the only guys who whenever we would talk
about our futures and stuff we would say
we wanted to film in TV oh nice so did a
couple times of us like hearing each
other say that for us to finally meet up
and be like go wait so you guys you
rushed together mm-hmm
same place class bust down the door no
it was it was a you know it's what you
see in the movies
sure so we can make assumptions about it
yes okay I'd rather you assume let me
tell you great that's fair so you guys
both rush you both made it I just made
it yeah apparently I feel like we both
barely made it for different reasons do
a lot of trouble sometimes together okay
yeah was it worth it yeah the stories
are so worth it yeah and so you guys
then you have this kind of meet-cute in
your rushing process what was that a
meet-cute like they say when riding a
movie like a meet-cute yeah yeah okay in
your Russian process and then you guys
do just start collaborating with each
other like was there a weird like
courtship with each other yes I was a
lot of sexting we had like talked about
it and then like after a while he came
in was ago I had this idea this one
buddy I want to do I've already sorted
making it's a frat videos okay cool so
write what you know which I would you
know yeah why would you know so I helped
him do that and then he put that up and
it was great and it took off people
loved it and then we were like let's do
some more stuff yeah so we would just
meet up like in one of our dorm rooms
and kind of brainstorm cool
the ideas we did we're both MLAs we come
home from the summer you're both
familiar okay we come home in the summer
and be able to still make videos
together nice and that was nice and and
you know how it goes from there the rest
is history is history and also present
history you guys are constantly writing
this narrative as we speak still going
yeah very cool
where did real bros come into play like
where did that idea come from yeah so we
were making this is like in several
years ago we were sitting down to write
a sketch we meet every week yeah that's
how he would work and we meet up like
several times a week and if like we're
not riding we're shooting if we're not
shooting we're editing or producing the
video we're gonna make for Monday right
staying busy right that gets tiring it
gets exhausting like we had hit a point
where we're just kind of exhausted and
kind of annoyed to by like you I mean
I'm sure you saw like the YouTube the
realm shift and the audience kind of
want different things yeah a lot of like
the evolution of YouTube is like
something you can't control
which gets very frustrating and yeah so
I fully relate to the idea of being like
I don't like the way this is going and I
don't know how I can participate it's
the way I want to so we were kind of
seeing that shift happen and we were
like man [ __ ] we don't even know if we
can like provide what these kids want
anymore like our sketches as much and
also making sketches is like a tedious
like that's the wrong word it's a lot of
work it is to the level of like with the
quality that we like them to be sure
it's a lot of hours and we just wanted
something bigger that lasted longer and
we wanted to you know a real budget and
we didn't have any of that yet like so
we were like let's just do a series
because we knew from before that we you
know if you shoot several things over
the course like a small period of time
you can like kind of release them and
slow release right do other things from
there you guys did okay to tangent a
little bit prior to real Bros you have a
few serious on Jimmy's channel like you
had yeah we have six great sleepover
series right we have a pop any
conversations yes drunk questions
I see the brand that's for me
you see I see what kind of fandom has
been created actually the fans like they
love the drunk questions on questions
grace yeah trust me as someone that has
also dabbled in drunk content it is a
physically demanding which is mentally
and emotionally demanding and when
you're watching the Edit you're like oh
my god there's like so much footage yes
oh god I know when you're drunk you're
like this is gold all of this is go we
don't even have to edit this and then
you watch it back you're like how am I
allowed to just hard when I'm sane we
can use maybe two minutes of this yeah
exactly so you guys had all these series
and so you wanted something just a
little meteor a little bit bigger like
production-wise and your that yeah and
one of our we were living together for a
bit and like one of our ongoing jokes
was like when we would scroll with like
the TV Guide there wasn't so many
reality shows that like we had never
heard of and like we thought were fake
at like some point oh this isn't real
good still might be fake like the true
cops of Calgary like what is that real
they have a TSA show what's in Canada
there's a reality show the TSA like a
Real Housewives I think we saw Real
Housewives of Potomac we're I'm a huge
reality TV junkie deal that's why I love
real Bros because I'm a real housewives
fanatic so thank you I like this I like
the way this has been translated this
makes sense to me I can process but so
you guys are scrolling through you are
and we just were like what's what's our
what's our reality show we're gonna do
one yeah and we like pretty quickly came
up with like the real Bros like okay it
seemed like a real bro show that's funny
we both like group like I grew up in the
valley la Valley
I went I grew up on a high school in the
valley okay so like we were both know
these kind of characters like these bro
he cared you've been around these types
of people right you're in your life yeah
first it was we had said like the rube
Rose of Valencia and like that was it
for a minute or like where was the Santa
Clarita and then Mike said a clear diet
I just come out so we're like nah
stay away from Santa Clarita and then it
was either Simi Valley that's a yeah
are there people or do you have to in
writing this this content because it's
obviously based in some sort of reality
of the way you guys grew up do you have
to dance around making direct references
to people that are in your real lives or
have you just gone there with like you
know I don't hold back but I also know
it's like it's based on like specific
specific people or specific incidents
like you know there are specific people
and specific incidences that have
inspired so it's kind of just like we
will throw all these ideas out yeah
some are experiences like things we
think are funny and will kind of weave
it together did you guys do did you
watch the reality shows that you were
looking up yes
how did that go it's tough everyone and
I I used to work in reality TV I was a
bj when I was like 17 to 19 I was 8 p.m.
what you work on The Bachelor and the
Bachelorette
why no longer even a show record player
scratch hold on what you worked as a PA
on The Bachelor yeah did you sign like a
crazy NDA I'm sure wait how was that
experience it's a lot of work cuz isn't
that job like you're like peers are work
hard always yeah not when you're running
around you're first to leave yeah yeah
and that show like that I'm sure like if
something comes up you have to be on it
to like capture it right and funny you
say that because my like second or third
year on that show I got promoted to an
assistant camera which I had no
experience besides shooting the sketches
like I just happen to be in the control
room and the director was like oh
somebody help on that camera and I was
like picking up trash in the floor
Christian get on that camera okay so
like they have a joystick that looks
just like that to control those like spy
cams in the house you know right right
this was bachelor pads it was all like
the rejection bachelor and all the
rejection by desperate people
the house just lit so I got to work
these cameras on the season Wow
[ __ ] I had to see so much sex and really
[Laughter]
the fornication is going on if someone
would like to document this right Wow I
mean they say you know Hollywood is a
glamorous industry okay so you have
experience in the reality TV well yeah
and I used to actually come home from
work and then like a shower and shower
and cry
yeah and I'm gonna put Jimmy to write
our sketches seems to be a summer break
and I would just tell him all the crazy
should I was sing and that later would
feel some of our right yeah maybe too
specific sure he actually came to the
mansion one time like a night shift like
after the like the load-out yeah yeah
you have to be off like 12 hours you
want to come through right here yes he
came he drove up to wrote there a couple
times it was cool okay we're gonna take
a real quick break and when we get back
I got more questions for you and then we
got a bunch of Twitter questions so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep oh yeah today we're talking about
the financial confessions every week on
the financial confessions host Chelsea
Fagan talks about money in a way you can
actually understand and gets the most
interesting people to share the money
truths mistakes and hard numbers they
normally never talk about money affects
all of us and yet remains a scary
awkward topic for most people the
financial confessions tackles money
head-on answering the questions most of
us are afraid to ask whether
interviewing Gretchen Rubin about the
way your personality type should shape
your finances learning from Graham
Stefan how he saves 99 percent of his
income or getting
Ingrid Nilsen to reveal the exact amount
of money she makes on YouTube Chelsea
makes money something people actually
want to talk about the financial
confessions is produced by the financial
diet a media company devoted to breaking
the taboos around talking about money
new episodes are published every Monday
and available on YouTube and all major
podcast platforms start listening to the
financial confessions today at the
financial diet.com slash podcast that's
the financial diet.com
slash podcast okay I could talk for
hours and hours just wanting to hear
every story you have from behind the
scenes that actually but let's talk more
about you okay and evolution of real
bros cuz now you're on the show you
write the show you direct the show Jimmy
directs the show Jimmy directs okay I'm
in his ear okay I got bug what what's it
and everyone that works on the show cuz
we've had a couple of the guys on every
one seems like genuine friends like real
real friends in real life yeah we are
all we're all pretty cool what's it like
working together in that like kind of
environment it's awesome yeah it's such
a privilege like you don't realize it
until you work on other projects yeah
[Music]
remember the days you're watching people
[ __ ] for free but it's great like I I
definitely am like stress cuz I want
this show to be good at all times when
she's on set like I'm definitely in the
zone you're professional right at the
same time like it's so great to be
laughing every day with people who like
you like and generally care about how
much of it is kept to script and how
much of it is kind of like playing in
the moment it's very scripted really
it's a very script even some of the
beats that seem like it's someone like
maybe pausing to like think of a joke
it's even that scripted we give them
definitely some room to improv like on
those like last take or two but first
for you you got to get a couple in the
can kudos I mean that's a testament to
how good they are at acting cause it
seems like it's very like loose yeah
everyone's kind of like I think after
watching themselves have kind of picked
up to tell them better and even gotten
more into it and like we're if a lot
yeah it's cool have there been any major
learning experiences or learning curves
in the previous two seasons of the show
you know what you can probably you know
relate to this it's very similar to how
do we were doing YouTube uh-huh in a
sense we're like you really have to just
do kind of where all the hats if you
want to come out a certain way like you
have to really if you want to control
like the final cut and final image like
there was a point I think when I got
into it where I was like oh there's
gonna be so great way to have such a big
team around us now I'm not going to
worry about so much stuff but I worried
just the same about every little thing
like I'm you're invested in the project
and the final product of it so by the
time this episode goes up it should be
out and available because it comes out
the 4th of February 14th 14th of
February for sometimes you're up yeah
it's hilarious oh what a great way to
debut it on Valentine's Day and in the
show episode one it's Valentine's Day
well oh wow I mean you're breaking walls
all over the place
I love the the marketing for it it feels
very bachelor esque it feels very like
in that reality TV zone are you in edit
for it right now still yeah this yeah
like up until basically you're working
on it that's so nuts it's a long process
because it's you know it's a lot of
angles it's a good amount of takes yeah
I mean it's funny because like reality
TV like a lot of it the shaping happens
in post but you made it right and this
isn't so much that cuz it's scripted but
there still is a little bit of room
where it's like oh well if we do this it
kind of comes off this way there's a
little bit of wiggle room to kind of
shape jokes a certain way so next time
it seems like it's just fun all the way
around it is fun I'm very excited for
how many seasons do you think this will
go 25 I mean cuz they definitely are you
know 50 year old bros out there yeah
yeah have you had any like for lack of a
better term real bros come up to you in
real life like saying like I get it yeah
oh yeah I've had yeah a lot of those
come up and say a lot of kids I saw a
lot of Halloween costumes the past two
years gonna ask have there been like how
is it influenced into pop culture yes a
lot of Halloween costumes then I click
some of the kids profiles I'd like
this is just you like are there any cuz
you guys have it's fun too because you
have like a mix of like these old-school
like actors and with like you know it's
my favorite part that's so cool
is there a dream like cameo of someone
on the show for you god dammit I should
know this because I just got asked this
recently Jimmy's was the rock which i
think was a great answer such a format
that you could really have absolutely
anyone hop into it
it'd be great yeah I think probably like
someone like Kid Rock would be pretty
funny
Wow the rock and Kid Rock realize okay
can I talk to you about this middle
school comedy yeah are you allowed to
talk about this yes to an extent okay
well tell me about it
what you can say about it it sounded
like tentatively called junior high now
mm-hmm based off another series you
started on YouTube yeah
the first of which was sixth-grade
sleepovers right and that came from so
we were at U of A in Tucson we stood
these drives back and forth between LA
and Tucson because like we signed with
like big frame back in the day and it
was like trying to collab with other
youtubers and take showbiz Hollywood
meetings and on those car rides you know
we smoked a bunch of and spoke a bunch
of while we we would talk about like all
the stupid stuff we used to do when we
were like 12 13 we always come back to
that and we would like little by little
share these like really embarrassing
stories but we used to do the same thing
so funny like just crack up and one day
we were just like man we really we've
made like a hundred jokes of why haven't
we like written anything yeah and so we
did sixth grade sleepovers and like we
loved it and a few more in seventh grade
eighth grade fifth grade recess wow
you're getting younger and younger age
but yeah once we saw once we saw like
kids actual kids around us which was we
did in fifth grade recess well wait hold
on this could be really funny yeah
and so you develop this into the show
that's now kwibi mmm Caribbean kwibi
which is the cutest name of that means
but I just love the way he sounds yeah
it sounds like you're trying to talk
underwater so you and Jimmy spent so
much time together do you guys have like
some unspoken rules of like how you
coexist with each other Wow no one I
have like I work with a lot of my best
friends give me some like well over the
year we know that we should not share
the same hotel room when we travel what
happened that made you get to that
though we well the three of my friend
had a memory and I used to travel
together and do live shows and then
mamrie and I would still room together
and Hannah would get her own room and
one time she came to our room to like go
over some stuff before the show and she
walked in she was like this is
disgusting we're meeting in my room I
can't no yeah you're right and then it
just eventually evolved it like oh we
don't have to pinch pennies we should
probably all have our own space we can
and it's not a personal thing right but
do you guys have any of those sort of
like the way you work to you know I
think we have a unspoken like radar
before when we're spending too much time
together yeah like we're like traveling
together or we've been on just working
day-in day-out like alright I'm leaving
bouncing I'll see you today her do
whatever it is there's also so much
content of the two of you on the
Internet at this point are there any
videos or situations that you've
regretted putting out into these Varig
reddit or those just buried so deep down
that you don't remember that's what it
is I mean like we don't pretty we don't
head first and like talking about
drinking and like smoking weed yeah
really agen like at first I was going to
nervous is like that's how my mom heard
about it for the first time oh really
yeah it wasn't just like mom I smoked it
was like man we smoked him blood
drinking on camera well my parents saw
me drinking in videos that my mom who's
like the sweetest but like a little
conservative she was like it's funny and
like unless she's kind of right she
doesn't know you can't have the video
out right this is the respectful part of
the beginning drinking I heard you're
doing dry January I am doing what's
going on with that it's just it's you
know your body reaches a limit which it
starts to physically tell you that you
should take a break yeah don't you think
you've come far enough it's like the 20
that I should just keep going you just
stop oh yeah no that is I'm three weeks
in and yeah it's the momentum shift of
it all because I heard that you like
Tito's thank you in February but this is
no this will be really great I'll put it
like in a glass box with a little
sledgehammer next to it Springs midnight
so sweet thank you what's your booze of
choice
lately it's been I like whiskey I drink
anything
yeah same but this is like my go-to he
does is I have to have some Cheetos yes
the best part I feel like it's a very
trendy now it is models drink it did you
see models models on Instagram no I
can't eat oh wow how I didn't see that
Wow do I feel in clear Davis okay what
uh what do you watch like what do you if
you don't have to work yeah like what do
you do for fun uh what do for fun I'm in
a book club Wow good for you that's very
mature sounding close with my Bros yeah
what is reading right now every didn't
this it's a nonfiction we just finished
three fiction books and most nonfiction
book called what the internet does to
your brain it was on Obama's reading
list so I was like guys I think we
should check this out how is it that's
[ __ ] terrifying really that's so sad
would you recommend reading it oh yeah
recommend it for sure but you're gonna
read some points where you're like damn
this
like personally attack so reading that
book club is great that's always fun
I play football when I can yeah what am
i watching no I watch lot of cartoons do
you yeah do you have in it you have an
animated project in the works yes I do
how's that so much fun is it actually
like things are happening there's
traction is happening yeah yeah yeah
well we're actually in the process of
working on a graphic novel comic book
for the series Wow also cool so what
haven't you done that you want to do
lots of gears right is there any like
real passion project that like you know
in the potential future it would be like
a dream there's a few honestly yeah but
it's like I gotta finish this stuff in
front of me first yeah yeah I learned
like if you're focusing on too many
things like nothing's getting full of
tension and then nothing ever gets
finished right yeah well how is the real
bros debuting it's not all launched at
once is it weeknight weekly that's
interesting my old school yeah no that's
not justa nation watching yeah that's
cool and it's on Facebook it's on
Facebook yeah and how has the working
with Facebook differed from YouTube for
you guys um well reading any support
from YouTube but face was great yeah
right yeah I mean do you notice like any
different trends in like the type of
people that watch over there because I
just don't use face I mean I dabble here
and there but it's still like unfamiliar
territory for me I think the biggest
challenge is just like people getting in
people's heads and like it's a
legitimate network with AK original
series that's like not a thing people
see it as still yet I think right right
your first destination is like Netflix
Hulu where you watch yeah teaching
people that how to watch out right
exactly it's almost teaching them how to
watch yeah hey there's stuff here like
come check it out yeah I am so we hope
that real bros can do that like come for
real bro as we hope you stay for other
stuff too
that's very generous of you I would be
like oh me watch my show yeah we want
the monopoly on this um what do you
watch YouTube still yeah yeah what do
you watch on YouTube I'll watch like I
watched a lot of interviews like
podcasts
I'll watch like Cody cows videos like oh
do you know well crack me up yeah yeah I
feel like I'm so far behind though in
YouTube singing I hate yeah it's too
much yeah when I go and try and scratch
the surface I'm being living Oh too much
too much to even try to decipher Tik Tok
getting some of the tic-tock tic-tock
okay I haven't ticked or talk to you
like a part of me I think every day
since like before the past well the part
of me is like I've never felt older than
looking at the tic-tock tic-tock app and
going I don't know what to [ __ ] this if
I [ __ ] up and just like post something
there's like wow how old is this guy
like over my head were you on vine back
in the day no my brain doesn't work in
that kind of content creation for
whatever reason I tried vine I tried I
just couldn't do it
I'm like this is too quick right fine I
thought the first time we saw something
it's a special skill and I just can't
and my brain can't bring it that way
which is I mean I guess for the bang
your brains beautiful the way it is
thank you you should write inspirational
books
that's one of my passion project books
the greeting cards yeah yeah so much fun
I I mean bring the art of like card
writing back to alright I think that's a
very personal intimate beautiful little
medium the writing letters lately that's
the new thing have yes okay you can get
a lot more letters to people like in my
life that I care about another beautiful
piece of reality you you would hate it
absolutely I'm gonna go watch it this
afternoon I got big plans huge plans are
you ready for the apocalypse oh man do
you doomsday prep no okay next question
you ready to die
I'm just this is I'm just using my
podcast to figure out who can save me
when I got you like thank you Costco
also I'm still trying to figure out if I
want to like keep going if the
apocalypse happens and like what's what
away yeah um your dog I have a dog
yes that's my baby girl yeah what's her
name Nala Nala what a sweetie
how was she she's seven she's old does
she come to set she doesn't come to say
okay because she's very social
she distract she distract everyone yeah
and she's run around like oh my god and
like I couldn't work and then it'd be a
whole oh I wish could bring her decide
where she was chiller to likable to
bring things that you'd like to try to
get on camera she's a diva right her
into the next season just saying yeah
that's my check I'm getting that check
to do so you get two checks cut for you
would you rather do a road trip in a van
across country with friends or travel
overseas in a private jet buy yourself a
private jet nah [ __ ] last part ah see a
road trip how many friends like seven of
us well you are in production because I
can see your actual because it's like
figuring out how the legitimate friends
okay let's say you have five friends
including me or no five friends that's a
lot or you solo on a fully-stocked
private jet
oh my going jet goes overseas nice
country Hawaii yes it can somewhere in
France I would probably do okay take the
jet by myself overseas okay on the way
there
invest in a bunch of stocks and when I
land cash the stocks out fly my friends
to meet me in Europe okay
no brand necessary all right I mean yes
you've you do have a
very methodical brain hanging but also
like that's a private jet yeah right
yeah okay what's a bad habit that you
really want to quit or tone down I drink
too much water humblebrag
I drink too much water and like I'm
constantly going to the bathroom and I
hate it so much 20 20 less water yeah
just get rid of all of it I know you
came in totally prepped okay we're gonna
take one last break when we get back
Internet the internet the internet has
questions for you we're almost mine
interview over the break we'll be right
back up or not you deep hey guys it's
your friend grace Helbig here the host
of the podcast that you are currently
listening to and hopefully enjoying
maybe even enough to leave a review on
Apple podcasts it helps people find the
podcast share all of the entertainment
spread the joy spread the pants shooting
stories you get it if you go over to
Apple podcasts leave a beautiful or dumb
review either way both help and
hopefully you continue to enjoy what's
you're hearing thanks we're back okay
Christian before we get into these
Twitter questions yeah I'm gonna ask you
the two questions asked every single
guest what is on the podcast and the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
yeah hold spaghetti yes sir oh man I
think my parents their life I did wasn't
even gonna ask meatballs is there sauce
oh is it just like the noodle
um I think you get to choose oh yeah I'm
give they're getting full is there a
reason Orange a senior yeah it's beef oh
it's beef right now
I've been beating with my parents like
two Christmases in a row two holiday
seasons in a row Wow yeah so like they
need to give
yeah it's not my fault is their fault I
can really see how this argument
probably started yeah oh you don't even
know grace so cold spaghetti The Pierces
as your parents watch the content that
you put out yeah yes they do do they
comment on it to you I know you
mentioned that your mom found out you
smoked because she yeah they talk about
it with me yeah disappointed are they
proud I would like to think they're
proud I don't know wouldn't tell me if
they were yeah they they they say things
to let me know that they watch yeah
every nun then they'll pitch me a sketch
idea oh that's sweet it's it's it's
funny how they do it like it's like
they're not pitching me a schedule yeah
yeah Oh have they had any good ideas are
they all a little off the mark they're
all pretty bad I'm sorry guys they're
gonna hear this
oh I mean they got mentioned so they're
doing their job what they wanted okay
the other question asked every single
guest is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or a close call but but
I'm going straight to it in my head
yeah it's sense-memory but you can only
use three words or three small phrases
so mine for example is college jogging
front lawn college yeah oh man at least
you made it to the front lawn it was the
only spot available not so much I made
it as I was watering the front lawn I
don't think so
I mean I do this day don't know okay
it's up in the air okay my three words
would be middle school okay God
auditorium and my seventh-grade crush oh
oh I feel like this story is probably
influenced some of the creative concepts
I put a lot of energy in blaming the guy
in front of me
that guy just shoot himself I'll be
right back that guy shoot himself
everyone should look at it so middle
school okay let's get into these Twitter
questions okay someone to know where do
you buy your clothes and what your
thoughts are on style in general oh
that's a good question yeah I I thrift a
lot how would you describe your style my
style is uh honestly I came up with
outfit sagdeyev it's a cool feeling I
think it's a pretty good representation
of how I'm feeling yeah I mean
especially because you grew up in Los
Angeles and so that's very like
influential area to grow up in in terms
of style I'm always just kind of like
been I remember from an early age like I
told my mom like all right stop look he
might close out seven I was like I've
always been into fashion style you said
I said love watching like like models
walking on ways on TV so really have you
ever wanted to get into that world of
being like a fashion influencer no no
okay no do you do you guys get to
approve like the Wardrobe obviously like
on set yeah that's very we're both very
involved oh really I mean that must be
the fun part
yeah yeah we have a great wardrobe team
that's cool we're also very much like
you guys do because no this no no it's
just I popped into my mind I used to do
this show called this might get at the
studio 71 studios face and we walked in
one day and there were just mounds and
piles and racks of like clothes that
look like a giant like vintage shop just
like puked everywhere and then we're
like what is all of this and like real
bros just wrapped it was like hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of pieces of
clothing was nuts well that's funny
because every time every now and then
I'm over that's the studio71 space and
like don't touch that that's that's
Grace's set oh yeah it was our set till
they stopped funding us they tried they
tried their best we turn it into
something positive a screen okay some
want to know what's the writing process
like for something like balcony
conversation
versus an episode of real bros oh very
different yeah could you mention that
like the balcony conversations just
seemed to have like a more casual
creative process yes yeah it's the same
so look how we would write is that I
would come up with sketch if the YouTube
channel is that means you meet up like
every week and like we have this long
list of sketches that we've been like
compiling concepts in 200 years yeah and
we would like look at the list and be
like okay I wasn't we wanna do this week
like what's funny what can we produce
time and money wise if there was
something on that list of like 50
sketches we go to our phones like oh
here's a funny idea I thought of well
and in whoever the funniest idea we were
just like that's the one we would beat
it out right there in the moment we
wouldn't be would script it right there
so it's kind of like just what feels
right at that time exactly yeah yeah and
then what's it like writing like an
episode of real Bros Bros is different
cuz you have to think with the entire
season in your mind right so although
you have a lot of funny ideas written
down like in your phone or notes and you
have like general concepts like on the
bullet white board it's like we have to
constantly be thinking about an entire
narrative in story arc and like like
we'll write a bunch of stuff in like
okay let's go to 10 now and make sure
that still makes sense bigger puzzle
exactly so is there any spoiler oh not
non spoilers that you can tell us about
the upcoming season any non spoilers I
will say oh man some definitely some
romance like the big overarching arc is
like a romantic one drama surrounding
that I guess you could say so we will
say the bros get international this
season cool I believe see me which is
pretty big maybe see me I mean that's
you know true to the influence cuz every
season of Real Housewives they take like
a girl's trip somewhere you go I'm not
gonna say okay okay this is similar to
what you kind of talked about sometimes
as I apologize if he answers just a lot
but what was the moment like when you
and Jimmy decided to make your first
video together mm because I feel like
that there's got to be a little bit of
like vulnerability there that you guys
like collaborate and creatively I
thank the real moment that was like a
defining thing was I remember win
exactly this was if it was like like in
the beginning of sophomore year or the
end of freshman year of college when we
were taking one of those drives to LA
from Tucson
somewhere in that like beginning we had
already added several videos out but
we're still gonna beginning stages where
we were driving back and the car got
quiet I think we're high for a second
and Jimmy was just asked music so like
like how far do you want to take this
thing I'm trying to do taken student
like trying to really gauge like how
like how in it I was yeah and I was like
dude I'm trying to do it it was like
okay that was it okay so we both know
that we're fully committed to this like
yeah now we can you know there's
something very very sweet about that
someone to know how do you feel about
being in front of the camera he's as
funny as Jimmy is but it seems like he
enjoys directing or behind the scenes
stuff more I want to see him more oh I
want to see any more - I love acting
dear I'm like in love with it I'm
addicted to it cuz yeah your character
in real bros did you wait that for
yourself we both wrote it okay yeah I
love acting I want to do it more as much
as I can I've always been obsessed with
like acting I think it was more like a
courage thing I didn't have the courage
to always say I loved as much as I
really did yeah and I think like that
kind of like got me off to a slower
start cuz I do love writing and
directing so much to like equally as
obsessed but I think because I was
already doing that more so I just lean
into like yeah this is what I'm doing
even though I've always this is more
available for me exactly was it easier
thing to say in conversation than
telling someone no I love acting but
then being like well why aren't you
doing it more that's like a so to them
hopefully we'll see more of me cool
someone snow do you have any funny
stories from the set of season three ooh
Oh God I'm sure there's funny stuff
happening all the time okay here's a
funny one I will say in the
International like day we were on
location shooting a little bit farther
away and there's a scene where two
characters are doing a sexual act okay
like one that takes some like
flexibility your ability to describe
this without giving anything we were
trying to make it tonight they were
doing this like well-known sexual act
like under the covers but you could see
their limbs kind of yeah and just
choreographing like we're all I mean
like me Jimmy were cracking up the
hardest like we were like crying I still
think it's the funniest thing so it's so
fun that's how you know it's like a safe
enough setec sex scenes and that just
makes people I think more excited to see
what that actually pertains to this
season definitely will there be another
drunk questions or hi questions the
people need it I think so I don't know
about my questions yeah but I think
there probably will be on the drunk
questions at least a few somewhere in
the future can't say win but we've
talked about it and we think it's coming
people know what your workout routine is
I work out every day I try to some kind
of physical movement yeah that's
swimming a lot lately
swimming yeah I don't swim I love
swimming but I hit the gym and lift some
weights and run on some things and throw
some things and it's fun
who is your NBA play style comparison my
NBA player style comparison I love
basketball I'm like the best basketball
player in the world star pie cycler Bron
James okay yeah okay very cool I
probably bran who is basketball your
favorite sport it was my first love
really yeah but I think I think
footballs a little bit more
who's your ula team's no I was born in
Chicago I'm Chicago times very cool very
cool yeah I'm from near Philadelphia
originally you guys fan eagles are the
most frustrating team to care about no I
didn't mind that he was until I lived
with an Eagles fan and I [ __ ] hate
guess you it's against him I get it I
when they won the Super Bowl I was like
oh my god that city is gonna destroy
itself
yeah insane yeah okay last question okay
what is your favorite way to get high
way to get high and you can answer this
or you can skip it I smoked a lot of
Jays I like rollin blunts blunts and J's
I paper some kind of paper and tobacco
situation come not to become very DIY
yeah you're constantly creating
Christian thank you so much for being
here
before you go debris guess that's on the
podcast you gave me a gift we give a
personalized fortune cookie
yes so that is from us to you let's open
it read it now absolutely I forget what
this one is actually doesn't it not come
true if you read it whatever I don't
know if you want this one here we go if
the Sun were the size of a typical front
door earth would be the size of a nickel
and you might think you don't need to
know that right now but you will later
on you're welcome
the [ __ ] yeah yeah that's the person
that made this fortune cookie might have
also rolled some blood and you're free
to use that where can people find you
and everything that you're working on if
they don't know yeah on Instagram you
can follow me at caps to Graham okay
mm zon the Mau make it real hard for
people to find you on is like a ball
a double check is really yeah change I
didn't one day and then you know check
out real brother Simi Valley season
three coming out Facebook watch February
14th Valentine's Day Valentine's Day
every Friday from then on out cool and
look I'm very much looking forward to
the kwibi show yes the animated show and
all these things and the other passion
projects thank you sir so I can't wait
to meet your mom thank you so much again
guys go check this out and go go go
watch real bros on Valentine's Day we'll
see you next time I'm not too deep
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Loni Eunice post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]